yes it is the long overdue recap of the
Wolverine to round out my summation of
the x-men film franchise just barely in
time before x-men days of future past
gets out obviously I think we were all
skeptical coming into this thing cuz
well we watched x-men origins wolverine
and thankfully this has zero to do with
that thing now it's interesting because
despite being the third film to come out
after x men the last stand it's the
first one to pick up with events
following that film everything else has
been a pretty cool so right off the bat
it's good to see things moving forward
again and it deals with the fact that
what happened in Xmen blast and
especially the wolverine was pretty
traumatic he's not in a good place when
this thing starts you know this was a
guy who went solo for a long time and
then he gets a hold of this group and he
feels like it's a family and well now
most of them are dead so he's just kind
of crawled off into cave and I'd say
he's waiting to die except yeah he
really kind of can't which had been a
problem in the last one but they
actually addressed pretty well this time
for a couple of reasons first of all
they deal with it head-on he gets
contacted by a guy whose life he saved
during the end of World War 2 over in
Japan this guy he's now old and dying
and says to him I can remove your
healing factor I can allow you to die so
first of all we're dealing head-on with
the fact that for all intents and
purposes Wolverine is kind of immortal
or at least is darn close to it second
of all he actually gets his healing
factor knocked out of whack in this film
it's not completely gone he's still
healing faster than a normal person
would but it's not working as
emphatically as it was and that is a
nice touch it's surprising it hasn't
been done up to this point to be honest
but the Japanese setting this is a
perfect setting because this is a
samurai story which is really what it
needs to be it knew they needed to tell
a story that was going to be unique to
Wolverine a big part of why x-men
origins wolverine didn't work was
because they took a story that was
supposed to be about Wolverine and tried
to make it in just another x-men movie
no this time they focus on what is
unique and specific to the
sky and it works just so much better i
also want to single out the japanese
cast i'm not going to go through names
cuz i'm gonna butcher them but a lot of
these characters are kind of generic on
paper but they cast really charismatic
actors for all these various roles
including the female in trouble
including her father who's a little bit
harsher you've got this mysterious ninja
character and they're all just so
magnetic on-screen that they work even
though you don't know a ton about them
and you've never seen them before I
think Hugh Jackman also does probably
some of his best work as the Wolverine
in this cuz he's always been gruff now
he's tormented and rightfully so it's a
mode that's been earned given what he's
been put through in the previous films I
really want to single out though in
terms of supporting cast oh she's good
she's awesome she just slightly weird
slightly quirky I hope she sticks around
to be honest I would love to see her and
Logan just as a team she's his sidekick
from now I think that would be great
there's been no sign of her however in
the trailers for days of future past
which bums me out a little bit but we'll
see the action scenes are really good in
this too again they seem to have learned
from x-men origins wolverine there are a
couple of green screen II you know lots
of special effects fights but they're
few and far between for the most part it
just feels real it feels impactful it
doesn't feel artificial the way that
x-men origins wolverine did so all of
that's running better to really almost
everything in this is a huge step up
there's a couple of stumbling points
though about the one area that this film
doesn't quite measure up is the only
area that x-men origins wolverine worked
in and that's villain there's nobody
here to replace liev schreiber as
Sabretooth I missed the guy I wish there
have been some way to get him into this
but it just it would have been forced it
probably wouldn't have worked but they
don't come up with a decent substitute
there they've got this female mutant
Viper that she never really worked for
me and then actually we've kind of an
overload of villains because we've got
Viper we've got the Yakuza we've got
this mysterious group of ninjas really
they spend almost as much time fighting
each other as they do fighting Wolverine
so we've kind of got villain overload
there's the twist at the end which I I
saw coming a mile away maybe I'm Jade a
little bit though cuz there were people
in the theatre that I could hear 100
when that happened at the end but i
don't know maybe I watched him any of
these things but I thought it was very
obvious but you know what it doesn't
matter because this is not a story where
the twist is necessarily important this
is a story about the Wolverine this is
about him this about his journey this is
about his character and the essence of
what he was and what he is trying to be
and it captures that beautifully I mean
this is easily one of my favorite x-men
stories that they've done I'm probably
going to put it as a third favorite
behind x2 and x-men first class and
pretty close third it's not a distant
way in the back they did really good
work on this and makes me cross my
fingers that will get at least one more
solo mission out of Wolverine before
Hugh Jackman decides he's too old for
the part so there we go x-men franchise
up to this point I will be back of
course to talk about x-men days of
future past when it happens but we're
not there yet until then this council is
adjourned